bonjour à tous et merci de nous
retrouver sur public sénat cette semaine
la commission d' enquête sénatoriale sur
le rôle des banques dans l'évasion
fiscale a poursuivi ses auditions mardi
les sénateurs ont entendu christian
noyer gouverneur de la banque de france
audition que je vous propose de suivre
tout de suite monsieur christian noyer
donc ouverte dans la banque de france
merci d'être parmi nous nous avons tous
et notamment à cause de la séance des
obligations à 18 heures donc cette
audition va être réduite dans sa durée
mais pas dans son intensité donc devant
la commission denquête vous devez prêter
serment donc je vous rappelle que toute
information relative aux travaux non
publique d'une commission denquête peut
être divulgué au publié qu'en cas de
faux témoignages sont passibles des
peines prévues par les articles 302 434
13,4 134,14 434 15 du code pénal
monsieur christian noyer prêtez-vous
serment de dire toute la vérité rien que
la vérité levé la main droite et jure je
veux très bien je vous remercie j'ai
donc passé immédiatement la parole à
notre rapporteur bien merci monsieur le
président monsieur gouverneur
excusez-nous de bousculer un peu le
timing mais on en sait un peu attardé
sur les auditions précédentes et nous
avons fêté nos engagements impératif à
18 heures donc voilà vous connaissez
l'objet de cette commission denquête
d'ailleurs les personnes que nous
accompagnons déjà eu l'immense bonheur
de participer le disions précédemment
donc nous sommes bien sûr le sujet de
l'évasion fiscale du rôle des banques
des acteurs financiers au sens général
les zones offshore etc et la supervision
également voilà est donc en premier lieu
je souhaiterais revenir sur les
expériences sont payants ce thème
général de la banque de france
relativement aux zones offshore qui joue
un rôle évidemment essentiel dans la
finance internationale aujourd'hui
exemples sont multiples donc je
souhaiterais que vous nous indiquiez
quelle importance vous leur attribuez
d'un point de vue à la fois quantitatifs
et qualitatifs
évidemment cette question est générale
mais peut être possible d'y répondre se
centrant sur l'appareil bancaire et
financier français
dans un premier temps à cet égard que
que vous inspire la la cartographie des
groupes financiers français et enfin
quelle responsabilité l'activité
bancaire et financière qui s'est
développé assez fortement dans ces zones
non régulés porte-t-elle dans la crise
financière démarrer maintenant il ya
cinq ans et non encore abouti dans ses
effets voilà une première série de
questions un peu général monsieur
gouverneur mais qui permettront de
monter un peu le décor merci merci merci
beaucoup merci madame la présidente
monsieur le rapporteur de vos questions
donc je pense qu'effectivement ce que je
pourrai répondre de façon assez assez
rapide et et les
précise à vos questions puisque vous
avez vu ce qu'on en sait long cadrage
général l'opportunité de vous êtes
beaucoup de questions à madame us cattin
général de la scpp donc je pense qu'il
ya beaucoup de choses qui ont dû être
couverte par par cela l'une des
difficultés que j'ai c'est que en
réalité si si on avait un monde de pays
normaux et un monde zones offshore qui
avaient tous les défauts de faibles
régulation caractéristiques d'un paradis
fiscal etc
le monde serait simple et on verrait
bien que les banques n'auraient la
demande dans ces zones que pour des
activités pas forcément au coeur du
financement de l'économie
évidemment quand on couvre des pays qui
sont des pays important économiquement
pour l'union européenne pour l'europe
pour pour notre économie pour nos
exportateurs comme la suisse l'autriche
le luxembourg et bien d'autres il est
évident que je ne peux pas donner une
réponse uniforme à votre à votre votre
vos questions alors quelle importance
quantitative et qualitative et si on
parle de certains pays comme comme ceux
que j'ai cités qui ont vraiment un rôle
économique majeur la suisse est un des
plus grands pays d'exportation pour les
industriels français donc il est clair
que c'est un pays qui a énormément
d'importance économique et qu' il est
normal que les banques françaises
d'accompagner les entreprises françaises
on sait bien qu'en suisse on peut avoir
d'autres types d'activités mais si on
prend l'activité gestion fortune à
laquelle vous pensez probablement candé
des résidents de france ou d'ailleurs
c'est vrai pour les d'autres grands pays
européens souhaité aller en suisse pour
des raisons qu'est qu'on peut imaginer
il faisait pas appel à des normalement
le plus souvent à des banques de leur
propre de leur propre pays et donc les
gestion de fortune concerne plutôt des
clientèles qui sont des clientèles
d'autres régions du monde et qui peuvent
éventuellement venir en suisse que j'ai
pris cet exemple on dans la plus
parfaite légalité de des pays concernés
ont des raisons diverses et variées de
diversification de gestion et de
patrimoine mais ça peut être tout à fait
légale quand on pense
des zones qui sont est par ailleurs il
est clair que la réglementation et le
contrôle prudentiel dans un pays comme
la suisse ont parfaitement assuré c'est
un des pays les plus exigeants en
matière de réglementation prudentielle
et de contrôle prudentiel donc en ce qui
nous concerne il n'y a pas d'inquiétude
particulière sauf à nous assurer ce que
nous faisons face en général les mêmes
données du vous expliquer cela tout est
fait en détails que nous attendons
énormément d'importance conformément aux
textes que dans nos veillant à
l'application à ce qu'il y ait bien dans
les banques françaises un contrôle
centralisé de de l'application des
réglementations et l'application des
règles anti blanchiment par exemple
écoute de contrôle des risques d'une
façon générale quelle importance
on découvre des pays qu'on considère
plus souvent comme des paradis fiscaux
certains pays des antilles par exemple
assez peu sauf pour des raisons
historiques et juridictions des créneaux
très particulier comme le financement
des navires
parfois il se veut le financement des
avions pour des raisons que je pense de
mon pied privé vous expliquerai mieux
que moi et ce sont des créneaux très
spécifiques l'activité des banques
françaises une dans ces zones en dehors
de ces créneaux très spécifiques et qui
sont des espèces de spécialités
économique est extrêmement faible
dernière question qu'elle est
le rôle joué par ces zones non régulée
dans le déclenchement de la crise
financière
à vrai dire j'ai ce sentiment qui n'est
pas très important
la crise financière est né de d'une
façon générale de l'accumulation de de
levier trop importants d'endettement
trop important des acteurs sur les pays
d des particuliers des entreprises des
systèmes bancaires trop de
transformation trop de trop de dette par
rapport aux fonds propres mis quelles
que soient les types d'acteurs est donc
sûre sur une construction qui était
fragile la diffusion de produits
innovants complexes mais qui n'était pas
caché qu'ils n'étaient pas fabriqués
dans des lieux secrets non réglementés
c'est bien aux états unis dans des
secteurs faiblement réglementés que se
sont développés les fameux conduit qui
comprenait beaucoup d'actifs financiers
dont
des instruments cdo qui était fondée sur
notamment le le risque de crédit sur
fond d' des prêts sociaux logement rsa
comme ça en europe mais qui est
souhaitée construit d'une façon
tellement tellement opaque que khalid et
la répartition du risque que cela était
censée permettre abouti à une suspicion
généralisée sur la valeur des actifs et
donc au déclenchement de 2,2 d'une crise
de liquidité puis au blocage des marchés
monétaires et des refinancements entre
banques
et ensuite à l'enchaînement nous avons
connu mais c'est bien dans un pays
particulièrement développée est supposé
avoir des réglementations de qualité que
des poches non réglementé ou mal
réglementée ou mal surveillés ont permis
l'accumulation de ces instruments qui
ont été le déclencheur de la crise
donc en fait moi j'en tire comme
conclusion que ce dont nous avons besoin
c'est vraiment de de progresser tous
ensemble au niveau international pour
boucher les trous fait en sorte qu' on
ne laisse pas échapper des pans entiers
d'activités financières à des règles qui
soient aussi commune que possible et à
une surveillance qui soit aussi
harmoniser que possible et évidemment
dans cet effort dans cette construction
on a un risque s'il ya des zones qui
sont non réglementé ou sont réglementées
non surveillée et qui sont prises et
parce que
et font elles sont attractives d'un
point de vue fiscal
là on a effectivement des risques et
donc qu'il est entièrement légitimes
plus que légitime que les états
s'unissent pour essayer d'éradiquer ces
zones de sault réglementation et de d2
sous fiscalité même si il est difficile
de dire quelle qu'elles aient joué un
rôle essentiel dans le déclenchement de
la crise
justement est ce robot est ce que la
titrisation qui a été un phénomène
moteur de cette crise financière n'a pas
pu se développer beaucoup plus aisément
dans les paradis fiscaux contenus de
l'opacité qui règne
l'expérience que nous avons eu je crois
c'est de la titrisation s'est développée
notamment aux états unis au grand jour
qui a pas eu en réalité de frein
suffisant mis à la sophistication des
produits à leur complexité et leur pas
citer la titrisation en soi peut être la
meilleure chose du monde
nous travaillons aujourd'hui avec les
grandes banques de la place
essayez de mettre au point d'ici d'ici
très peu de temps d'ici l'automne pour
là pour le rentrer un produit de
titrisation qui sera un produit de
titrisation de créances sur les pme qui
pourrait être à la fois un instrument
d'investissement pour les compagnies
d'assurances donc sans des crédits
l'idée sous des crédits aux pme mis en
place par des bandes qui en conservera
une partie qui en titrisant une partie
ce sera un instrument tout à fait
transparent pour faire la liste des des
crédits aux pme
ces crédits reçoivent une note donnée
par les services de la banque de france
et donc on sort et quelle est la nature
du risque son évolution pour savoir
exactement quel est sont les pm financer
ce serait donc un instrument
d'investissement comme je le disais qui
peut être utilisé par les compagnies
d'assurances gouvernement souhaite
développer leurs capacités de
financement des pme
ça pourrait être un instrument
d'investissement de sicav de différents
différents types de deux produits
d'investissement ça c'est vraiment la
titrisation dans son bon aspect et nous
avons essayé au niveau de l'eurosystème
la bce au système en général de
favoriser des types leur la renaissance
d'une titrisation simple transparente
que les anglo-saxons appellent parfois
vanille c'est à dire une chose qui est
un produit simple et d'une seule couleur
dont on peut mesurer le risque est qui
qui permet effectivement de contribuer
au financement de l'économie
et là où la titrisation devient
dangereuse c contient des produits
très différents que personne ne sait
exactement comment la composition est
fait quand on fait des produits qui
eux-mêmes complexe qui eux-mêmes
incorpore au premier niveau des produits
complexes dans ce qu'on appelait décidé
au deuxième degré de troisième degré et
à la fin on a quelque chose qui se vend
et qui s'achètent dont il est
extraordinairement difficile de
connaître la composition est là est la
vraie valeur et c'est ça qui a été le
grand la grande étincelle de la crise
mais ça s'est développé ces produits
complexes sont développés au grand jour
à new york donc c'est simplement parce
qu'il n'y avait pas les réglementations
nécessaire ou la supervision nécessaire
que ça puisse développer comme cela ce
gouvernant vous êtes donc en tant que
vers leur également président de la scpp
nous avons auditionné tout à l'heure que
à quelle limite de la transparence des
des grands groupes financiers
multinationaux avez vous été confronté
dans cette activité
je ne pense pas qu'il y ait de limite à
la transparence dès lors que
les choses sont que ce que nous
cherchons à savoir et bien rentre bien
dans nos attributions
donc quand il s'agit cependant d'un
groupe qui a son siège à l'origine en
france
je pense que nous obtenons tout ce que
nous voulons savoir à la fois sur toutes
ses activités en france ont toutes les
activités et des succursales de l'union
européenne ou donc dans l'espace
économique européen puisque nous sommes
responsables du contrôle même de chacune
des entités de même de ses succursales à
consommer sont situées ailleurs lorsque
nous sommes en présence de succursales
en dehors de l'espace économique
européen ou de filiales
là nous avons il faut distinguer entre
ce que nous pouvons et ce que nous
exigeons bien sûr pour pouvoir asseoir
notre contrôle consolidé qui est une
représentation fidèle des risques pris
et puis le détail des opérations qui
relève des superviseurs locaux alors ce
que nous avons ce sont comme nous nous
sommes concentrés et nous en avons les
moyens dans la réglementation c'est de
veiller à ce que tous les groupes est un
contrôle centralisé des risques et un
contrôle centralisé des procédures quand
je dis les risques ça comprend non
seulement les risques de contrepartie de
crédit les risques de taux de change
partout également les risques de
conformité donc le fait de ne pas de se
donner les moyens de savoir si une
filiale ou une succursale quelque part
dans le monde se livre à des activités
qui
soit des activités qui leur font courir
un risque non seulement d'image mais de
reproches et de condamnation c'est
évidemment un risque qui doit être pris
en compte
d'être couverts donc nous veillons à ce
qu'elle ait des systèmes en pole des
risques qui couvre bien tout est et je
n'ai pas le sentiment que nous nous
soyons jamais heurter à des refus mais
évidemment nous demandons des choses qui
sont ce que la loi nous permet de
demander et il nous avons le sentiment
que ce que la loi nous permet de
demander une augmentation nous permet de
demander ce que nous pensons obtenir
effectivement nous suffit à contrôler
les risques pris par l'ensemble des
banques
bien entendu l'histoire a démontré que
avec les meilleurs systèmes de contrôle
on n'était jamais sûr de voir absolument
tout pour la simple raison que même si
la gendarmerie est très efficace et même
si le code de la route est extrêmement
précis il est impossible de s'assurer
qu'on n'aura jamais un chauffard qui
sans permis de conduire qui va prendre
illégalement le volant d'une voiture
avec un degré d'alcoolémie excès
excédent traître de beaucoup ce qui est
permis et provoqué un accident parce
qu'on peut pas avoir un gendarme dans
chaque voiture mais
mais ceci étant notre sentiment est que
nous n'avons pas de deux limites réelles
qui nous qui serait un obstacle à notre
à notre contrôle nous avons eu une une
petite difficulté non prévue qui est la
suivante dans un certain nombre de cas
puisque pour pour pour vérifier la
réalité du mécanisme de de contrôle des
risques de gestion des risques de
remontée d'informations vers la maison
mère y compris sur les questions de
lutte anti blanchiment sur les questions
de conformité
nous avons besoin de faire par sondage
des contrôles sur place
dans certains cas ce contrôle sur place
se font dans le cadre d'un accord
international n'en existe quelques uns
et donc donc ça me pose aucune
difficulté puisque c'est prévu c'est
prévu expressément par la loi depuis
longtemps dans certains cas il n'y a pas
de tels accords
et donc nous avons l'habitude de
demander l'autorisation superviseur
local de conduire une enquête ciblée sur
ce ce que nous souhaitions vérifier et
dans la plupart des cas nous obtenons
des réponses favorables y compris dans
des territoires dont certains figurent
jean la lys que vous saviez dressée
comme les grandes places financières
asiatiques hong kong singapour où
certains certaines places des antilles
et file dans la plupart des cas vous
avez une réponse varin depuis on a eu un
cas ou sur la base de des résultats
d'une enquête nous avions initié une
procédure la cpv initie une procédure de
sanctions font pousser et la commission
des sanctions a jugé que nous n'avions
pas la base juridique nécessaire c'est
un son pour laquelle nous avons indiqué
au gouvernement que nous souhaitions
avant une base juridique qui nous
permettent de couvrir ça et le
gouvernement a proposé au parlement dans
qui est en délibération devant devant
votre assemblée bancaire la disposition
qui nous permettra de continuer à faire
cela mais le faire avec une base
juridique incontestable que la
collaboration des superviseurs locaux
dans les pays où est implanté le secret
bancaire
comment ça marche dans ces conditions là
dans les pays qui ont et qu'ils ont une
une réglementation et un contrôle
sérieux et exigeant
nous ne rencontrons aucune difficulté
puisque ce que nous recherchons ce sont
les procédures en place les mécanismes
de surveillance des risques à monter
d'information la solidité des
différentes filiales et succursales et
encore une fois prenez la suisse par
exemple les exigences en matière de
fonds propres en matière de contrôle des
risques sont tout à fait aux meilleurs
standards internationale donc pour la
tâche qui est la nôtre et l'objectif qui
est le nôtre nous n'avons pas rencontré
de difficultés il faut aller dans des
petits territoires où l'autorité de
contrôle est assez faible pour être
confronté à parfois à des cas ont
l'impression que
les informations pas forcément par
mauvaise volonté mais les informations
cédé par le superviseur ne sont pas
forcément de extraordinairement précise
et ça peut être des cas ou si
l'important c'est significatif pourtant
des activités significatives nous
souhaitons aller voir pour voitures que
qui a en réalité un contrôle des risques
qui est bien fait une remontée
d'informations sûres sur ses prises de
risques et plus généralement sur le
fonctionnement de la philo succursales
qui est suffisante de la maison mère
dernière question avant de passer la
parole mes collègues éventuellement sur
le la résolution devant la résolution
l'appréhension de la crise financière de
ces dernières années
est ce que vous diriez que le la
responsabilité des banques est
directement engagée de par certains
manquements au respect des règles
prudentielles par exemple
quel est calé cette responsabilité à vos
yeux et quelles mesures ont pu être
prendre concrètement pour garantir la
non survenue de nouvelles crises dans
les années qui viennent
très prochainement éventuellement
comment appréhendez vous ce point le
gouverneur je pense que prioritairement
la réglementation n'était pas
suffisamment adapté
la crise nous a montré d'abord c'était
en partie une crise de liquidité au nous
quitter c'est bloqué nous avions en
france une réglementation de la
liquidité elles existaient dans certains
pays ce n'est plus en vie nationale pas
de règles internationales
on peut discuter pour savoir si elles
étaient suffisantes et les règles
attention elles vont être plus plus
rigoureuse que celle que nous avions
enfin nous en avions une qui a
relativement bien fonctionné mais il ya
un sentiment de pays qui n'avaient
aucune règle est là et là on a vu que
cette insuffisance était et est très
consulté un risque risque majeur
deuxièmement l'expérience nous a montré
que les exigences de capital ne donnait
pas un coussin suffisant les règles
internationales d'abord un n'avait pas
été entièrement transposer dans certains
pays aux etats-unis elle a été
transposée règles de bâle 2 mai lire les
américains avaient par ailleurs d'autres
règles mais qui en réalité partout les
coussins de capital demandée était
insuffisant et notamment insuffisant au
regard de certaines opérations comme les
opérations marché de la titrisation et
donc il fallait pas tout tout l'effort
qui était conduit ces dernières années
par le g20 pour c'est le stabilité
financière comité de bâle et beaucoup
d'autres tout ça est un continuum a
consisté à relever les exigences à créer
des exigences de liquidité intercim la
relever les exigences de solvabilité le
relever notamment le poids de des
opérations dans les demandes de fonds
propres solutions d'opérations de marché
d'opérations risquées à développer le
contrôle
alors il ya des pratiques on peut dire
les banques on avait ces pratiques
étaient dangereuses mais il est vrai que
nous n'avions pas de règle ni nationale
ni internationale qui les empêchent
d'aller dans cette direction
je pense par exemple aux politiques de
rémunérations il est clair que le
développement de
rémunération variable de bonus pour
parler langage habituels qui était
fondée sur la rentabilité immédiate
d'opérations et on sait bien que une
façon de faire des profits immédiats
important c'est de prendre beaucoup de
risque évidemment l'image est différente
quand on regarde quelques années après
la réalisation des risques et donc les
pertes qui sont à mettre au regard des
profits quand les rémunérations sont
alignés sur les profits il tient par
contre des pertes éventuelles futures
on a une risque de déformation de la
structure des opérations il est clair
que tout l'effort qui a été fait pour
mettre des règles internationales sur
ses rémunérations variables obligé à ce
qu'ils en aient une partie différée une
partie réglé en actions de la banque qui
donc intéresse aux résultats pas
seulement aux profits mais mais mais
aucun des éventuels pour pour pour
limiter donc le biais à la prise de
risque ou le contrecarrer
ça c'était très important donc les
banques qui ont été un peu imprudent les
réglementations étaient absentes dans ce
domaine et on a vu à l'expérience que
cet état que c'était une mauvaise chose
et qu'il fallait corriger
il ya sans doute sans doute des pays où
les dés les risques pris par les banques
ont été beaucoup plus excessives qui
n'ont été en france notamment
lol parce que certains pays n'avaient
pas l'habitude d'avoir une supervision
très intrusive comme nous avons en
france
et parce que il y avait des domaines sur
lequel ils pensaient que là il ya le jeu
des forces du marché équilibré
automatiquement les choses nous avions
la réputation n'étions pas les seuls
nous avions la réputation avant la crise
d'être plutôt une autorité de contrôle
tatillonne et et empêcheur de tourner en
rond si j'ose dire je veux dire que ce
n'est plus du tout entendu ce reproche
après le déclenchement de la crise par
aucune des banques que nous
surveillerons ge pensent qu'ils sont ils
ont un peu stérile en tout cas précis le
fait que et je le dis pas ça pour des
coûts n'ont pas commis d'erreur en tout
le monde
tout le monde a sous-estimé les les les
vulnérabilités du système
mais mais il ya quand même eu beaucoup
moins de deux problèmes chez nous
qu'elle a eu dans beaucoup d'autres pays
oui je vais passer la parole à corinne
bouchoux ensuite j'aurai une question à
vous poser
nous avons les poser si vous le voulez
bien toutes les deux ensemble comme ça
vous pourrez y répondre globalement et
puis je repasserai la parole à notre à
notre rapporte à monsieur gouverneur
nous venons donc en saison 2 suite à nos
travaux de l'an dernier est ce que le
nom il n'y avait pas un paradoxe à une
nounou en quête de transparence et de
cerner au plus près les systèmes et
l'ingénierie la fraude et l'évasion
fiscale et d'un autre côté nous avons vu
cela dans la presse il ya huit jours
tout le monde écoute tout le monde tous
tout le monde sait tout sur chacun et
donc là est ce qu'il n'ya pas je dirais
quelque part un paradoxe qui fait que la
situation est connue de tout le monde
mais que pour des raisons du savoir
vivre ensemble et puis dans l'intérêt
des affaires tout le monde continue avec
la couverture où je dirais la casserole
sur la cocotte minute pour essayer de
2,2 le couvercle sur la cocotte minute
pour essayer d'éviter un grand déballage
il ya quand même eu quelques ces
dernières ces derniers mois des
révélations dans la presse des listes où
circulent et c'est donc est ce que en
gros vous pensez qu'on est allé au bout
du déballage et qu'on va pouvoir passer
à une autre ère où on est encore dans
une époque délétère où on va être à la
merci comme ça de deux révélations de
rebondissements voilà donc qu'est ce qui
a changé en gros depuis l'an dernier
c'est ça ma question
oui c'est le gouverneur moi j'ai une
question un peu plus prosaïque y est un
peu toujours la même avec toujours le
même type d'exemple que inside job qui
évidemment là là le nec plus ultra de la
décomposition ou des autopsies de la
crise
croyez-vous qu'on est avancée en matière
de règlement des conflits d'intérêts
parce que nous avons dans cette maison
en ce moment même un texte sur sur la
prévention des conflits d'intérêts les
déclarations d'intérêts et ça c'est
quand même majeurs puisqu'on a vu aux
états unis les dégâts que ça avait
occasionné avec un mélange des genres
entre les parlementaires les gouverneurs
et les grands financiers y compris
goldman sachs qui gouvernent le monde
selon un ouvrage désormais connue et
diffusée
donc comment pensez vous qu'on puisse
régler peut-on de régler mieux les
conflits d'intérêts qui sont quand même
aux au centre d'un certain nombre de
difficultés et il nous a pas échappé que
nous avons entendues à quelques semaines
dominique strauss kahn qui lui nous a
expliqué qu au fond monétaire il avait
quand même évaluer le besoin en
refinancement des banques y compris les
banques françaises à un niveau beaucoup
plus important que celui qui avait été
annoncé est-ce que vous pensez que de ce
point de vue là la situation est
totalement apurer en ce qui concerne en
tout les cas le système français et
européens merci sur sur la question du
paradoxe
edu et du couvercle nous nous avons
progressivement ça veut pas de la crise
va commencer avant nous ont fait
énormément de progrès dans le monde des
superviseurs sont les échanges
d'informations les échanges
d'informations elles sont pas
automatiques complètement encore qu'il
ya des choses qui sont qui sont partagés
mais en tant que de besoin de nous
échangeons des informations nous
pourrons faire des enquêtes sur des
complots sur place j'ai évoqué ça j'ai
l'impression que ce qui est en train de
se construit avec le trouve pour ma part
complètement logique et nécessaire parce
que c'est comme ça que nous avons réagi
dans le monde de la supervision et pour
la la détection des risques et le
contrôle global de la vulnérabilité des
groupes financiers ou bancaires
c'est justement de procéder à des
échanges d'informations une coopération
active et c'est la seule façon été de
croiser les informations et de d'avoir
une image fidèle de ce qui se passe à
lormont nous notre notre domaine d'une
certaine façon plus facile puisque nous
nous intéressons à des entités à ce
qu'elles font
on a relativement pour n'a pas des
millions d'entités devant nous nous
avons des centaines de d'entités
entreprises en quelques sortes de
groupes parfois complexes que très
complexe mais enfin c'est quand même
limité c'est peut-être une tâche encore
plus difficile en matière fiscale
puisque on a affaire potentiellement pas
seulement à des groupes
il ya aussi les fautes fiscal certains
montages célèbres comme les carrousel de
tva mais mais mais potentiellement à des
individus mais malgré tout je pense que
c'est vraiment la voie la seule voie de
progrès et donc et donc je pense que
c'est ça qui change
récemment c'est donc une véritable prise
de conscience et un mouvement général et
à partir du moment où les états unis et
l'union européenne où les grands pays de
l'union européenne sont d'accord pour
aller dans une direction c'est vrai que
c'est si les mêmes causes produisent les
mêmes effets ce que j'ai vu en matière
de réglementation prudentielle c'est que
ça mouvement qui submerge assez vite
tout le monde parce que c'est plus
difficile d'y résister sauf à se
singulariser et à s'exclure du jeu du
jeu économique mondiale soit
marginalisée en tout cas sur la question
des conflits d'intérêts jeu
cette passion de de savoir très bien
répondre à cette question je pense que
c'est une question de pratique de
déontologie doriz interne il se trouve
que nous avons en france des autorités
de contrôle en tout cas l'autorité de
contrôle prudentiel pas parler pour les
autres métaux étaient contre potentiel
dans le domaine de contrôle des banques
des assurances est une autorité qui est
essentiellement constituée enfin le losc
est un général on sombre actifs est
essentiellement constituée d'agents
c'était une terre de la banque de france
donc des gens qui sont comme des
fonctionnaires qui passe pour la plus
majorité d'entre d'essentiel ou la
totalité de leur carrière en tout cas
qui va l'intérieur de l'univers banque
de france où quelques détachements
ministère des finances ou ailleurs mais
et donc vous avez une une culture de
service public et d'indépendance qui est
très qui est qui et tout est fait
incontestable dans tous les pays n'ont
pas forcément la chance d'avoir cette
tradition ce statut et les choses sont
plus difficiles
moi je je crois que il faut dans chaque
pays traités traiter les choses de cette
de cette façon là avec des règles
déontologiques des règles de
surveillance nous avons la banque des
règles de déontologie commandement au
sein de l'appareil d'état qui sont très
précises pas dire que on n'aura jamais
ou qu'on a jamais d'accident mais mais
en tout cas il faut avoir des procédures
très précises des règles une
surveillance des règles des institutions
des déontologues etc pour poursuivre
cela et c'est sûr et des règles sur le
départ des procédures avec une
commission fin nous avons la même chose
que ce qui était mis en place au sein de
l'état pour nous assurer que nous
limitons au minimum les risques de
conflits d'intérêts en ce qui concerne
les besoins de refinancement je ne
partage pas l'avis dominique strauss
kahn le fmi a toujours été assez
pessimiste meierhans en réalité ils
étaient pessimistes d'une façon générale
sur l'europe quand on les pousser dans
leurs retranchements il était quand même
plus pessimiste sur certaines zones en
europe et malheureusement l'expérience a
prouvé que en effet il considérait à
juste titre sans doute que notamment les
conditions dans lesquelles des bulles
immobilières s'étaient développés dans
certains pays européens je pense à
l'irlande je pense au royaume uni je
pense à l'espagne
peut-être un autre
été un élément de fragilité qui n'était
pas couvert suffisamment parpaings des
provisions que donc pourrait amener des
pertes et des besoins de
recapitalisation et l'histoire a donné
raison sur ce plan là mais d'une façon
générale à l'idée de dire que les
banques européennes sont moins
capitalisées que les banques américaines
ce qui est assez à la mode aux états
unis au fmi n'est pas ne correspond pas
à la réalité telle que nous nous
l'analysons à tort ou à raison
quand nous regardons par exemple des
mesures très frustré l'effet de levier
quand on corrige des différences de
normes comptables
on trouve un effet de levier qui est
exactement le même quand on prend les
trente plus grandes banques américaines
et 32 grandes banques européennes
aujourd'hui ça veut pas dire est que
cette scène dit rien sur la situation de
deux ou trois petites carassou d'autres
petites banques ici ou là mais le
système bancaire dans son ensemble si
l'europe est sous capitalisée c'est à
dire que les états unis sont aussi sous
capitalisées pour ya aussi un consensus
assez large dans le monde aujourd'hui
pour dire les banques américaines ont
fait tout ce qui était nécessaire
on peut pas dire l'un et son contraire
et moi je je je pense honnêtement que
nous avons trouvés dans le monde
d'aujourd'hui le un équilibre qui est
sans doute petit mal entre
le souci de recapitaliser très fortement
les banques pour leur donner un coussin
une capacité de résistance et donc en
cas d'accident d'être capable de
surmonter l'accident sans faire appel
aux contribuables
et puis l'objectif de ne pas m'être
demandé trop de capital parce que si on
demande des ratios capital trop élevé
dans cette décennie
le résultat sera un risque de réduction
du crédit de réduction des bilans et
donc de non financement de l'économie
ça voudrait dire aggravé le la phase de
ralentissement mondial et rendent plus
difficile la reprise
je pense que nous avons trouvé après
beaucoup de tâtonnements quelque chose
qui sans doute l'optimum je sais pas
comment je jure à l'optimum en 2025
mais dans la décennie nous sommes
personnellement je recommande de d'en
rester là sauf à ajuster sur des détails
qui peut toujours regarder de plus près
tel type d'opérations de marché tel type
d'activité on a encore des choses à
faire qui sont importantes notamment sur
les dérivés notamment sur la
compensation des dérivés du maximum de
dérivés au tc ou le suivi en tout cas
d'andy registre transparent pour tous
les obtiens valent pour tous les
superviseurs de toutes les opérations y
compris celles qui sont faites sans
compensation dans une chambre centrale
et le calibrage des exigences de marge
qu'on mettra sur dérivés c'est vrai
qu'il n'est pas fini
l'empilement des dérivés d'une façon
opaque a été à mon avis un des facteurs
déclenchants de la crise en tout cas de
l'épisode lehman brothers aussi
important que
les cdo même où les instruments d autres
instruments complexes donc c'est cette
question et dérivés pour moi d'une
importance extrême il faut absolument
que nous ayons une réglementation et
pour que ça fonctionne
nous avons besoin de soins aux règles
internationales elle est prête d'être
d'être mise au point je pense qu'avant
la fin de l'année nous aurons un système
qui sera effectivement au point et la
mise en oeuvre pratique déjà commencé
avec la la préparation des
infrastructures nécessaires oui donc je
n'ai plus de questions de grenoble sur
le temps malheureusement imparti est
écoulé désolé de bousculer ainsi le
timing est donc les dernières questions
figurent sur le questionnaire qui nous a
été adressée donc bien sûr nous serons
satisfaits de recevoir les réponses
étaient sur chacune de ses questions sur
voila je vous remercie bien sûr du
rapporteur frustre la commission je ne
doute pas que vous soyez tout aussi
frustré monsieur le gouverneur mais le
cas échéant je pense que nous aurons
d'autres occasions de nous revoir ce
sujet qui n'est pas encore clos merci en
tous les cas d'être géniaux que j'aurais
à la disposition de mission merci non
l'impression voilà pour les travaux de
la commission d' enquête sénatoriale sur
l'évasion fiscale si vous souhaitez
revoir cette audition ou en savoir plus
sur la commission denquête notre site
internet publicsenat.fr bonne journée à
tous